warning this episode may contain content
that is not suitable for children viewer
discretion is advised so tell me this
sexual harassment and sexual abuse
sexual abuse is in this and at the
bottom it says gang rape is featured as
a character being Chained and choked
Pepe Lew is pushing rape culture but we
literally have gang rape and sexual
abuse and this is not cancelled tell me
why
what's up everybody thank you for
joining us at LED live we got to talk
about this show because everybody has
been sending it to us I actually heard
about this show about two years ago
somebody sent it to me and said you got
to look at this it's super satanic and
I'm like okay well it's on YouTube
anybody can make anything a show about
anything on YouTube and and so I was
like it's blatantly satanic anybody
should stay away from this especially a
Christian there's pentagrams everywhere
so some things it just seems like we
shouldn't have to cover it cuz it's like
it's right there in your face it's
satanic there's nothing to really expose
but uh when Amazon Prime picked this up
and made it mainstream that's when I was
like wait a minute there's something
different going on now because we have
entered into an era where Satan doesn't
even have to hide anymore it used to be
uh these Gnostic stories or these
satanic stories were sugarcoated and
some other kind of Disney story where
you can't really tell it you have to
kind of peel apart but over the years
it's been like the frog in the kettle a
little bit you know we'll we'll see
we'll push the limit a little bit more
and oh they were okay with that well
we'll keep going out and now you got
Anime called the seven deadly sins and
they're the heroes and the Ten
Commandments are the bad guys so that's
where we're at and now Amazon Prime has
picked up this show has been hotel and
it's not some small thing in the corner
anymore it was even when it was on
YouTube it had millions of people
following it
but when you look at Amazon Prime's
official YouTube channel they are just
displaying this thing everywhere and
it's getting millions of views uh in
less than a week so just looking at this
picture do you guys see anything
interesting in the picture when I first
saw this I thought oh like that's a
pretty like ornamental kind of design
and then your house walk probably
without even looking at it cuz it's
crazy I didn't know but then when you
look at it there's three snakes actually
it's like in a trinity format there's
also an apple in between the two of them
and then they're also hands is that like
hands yeah you see the hands around like
the antlers and stuff I don't know that
looks like like the head of a snake from
upper level and then the mouth looks
like a
dragon actually it looks like a dragon
too from the bottom yep there's a
compass back there too oh Freemason
compass is there right there yeah is oh
wow so we've actually did a little bit
of a a reaction video to this Britney
has not she has no idea what this is so
I'm interested to hear her take on it
we've all kind of seen some of it but
not some of these other things so what
is hasbin Hotel um we're going to let
the news tell us because this really
shocked me I didn't realize that we're
at a time where mainstream Media news is
supposed to be telling you what's going
on in the world
is actually saying hey go check out this
new show called hasman Hotel let's just
watch this love
every this place is about second chances
to convince Heaven the people of hell
can be redeemed hi mister don't yourself
have you ever wanted something that was
so clear in your mind that you could
taste
it you're going to help Sinners
hilarious so if our next guest only knew
how much one of The Producers here loves
her show for months now we have been
casually reporting on the Animated
Series hasb been hotel to the point if
an actor signed on we reported it if a
musical number dropped we reported it it
became a running joke around here and lo
and behold the joke was on us because
when hasb been Hotel dropped on Prime
video it became the top 10 most viewed
in the world is the success a social
prize it it is every single time like
when I made the original pilot that was
a surprise like it had a an audience
like I had been building you know just
being online but it exploded and I was
like whoa and so the series has kind of
been the same thing I was like oh boy
there's a lot of anticipation and
there's a lot of excitement and I hope
it lives up to it and so the the fact
that people are liking it I'm like yay
it happened again when you when you talk
about this pilot though this was
something you originally put online but
it had Millions upon millions of views
yes I think it's currently at like 93
which I'm like oh my God like not even
93 million I'm like wow it's insane I
have no idea how that happened so I
would imagine that worked as as like the
hook for getting this on yes okay we
figured we'd bring out Andrea just to
say hi maybe maybe she's got a couple
things on her mind anything you want to
say now that your idol is here go for it
Andrea I just want to say Vivian you are
a source of the inspiration for me and
ever since I first saw hasb been Hotel
it has
really imp meant so much in my life
and I have to say this is probably one
of my most favorite shows ever hands
down which is a lot to say because I
love to attack on Titan I love Black
Butler but husband on Hotel came right
on top Vian we thank you so much thank
you for yeah your success is
unbelievable what an inspirational story
so if you're interested in checking out
hasband in hotel don't forget you can
find out on Prime video final two
episodes of the season will be released
next Thursday for the us if you don't
have Prime video you can find the First
full episode for free on Prime video's
YouTube page we'll be right back I just
never dreamed a show like this when you
actually realize how bad it is how
explicit it is and for mainstream Media
news they' be like check it out we're
going to interview the the Creator but
it is number 10 it it right now it's the
top 10 top 10 yeah of all things not of
Animation not of
shows about hell of everything watched
it's in the top 10 that's pretty that's
pretty telling of where we're at in
society is this marketed to Children it
is or is it just general like kids could
just come across it and watch it it is a
rated TV MA but we're going to we're
going to look at who's the most like the
biggest population of people watching
okay okay so where do you find apples
and snakes well definely not in the
Bible because it never said it never
said it was
appal it just said it was a fruit and I
know I would not lose my salvation over
an apple
but isn't that crazy like you have to
know that this is about the symbolism
yeah I mean look I when she came out she
was wearing these pants and I was like
is that snakes and I I looked it up sure
enough she was wearing apples and I did
find the pants he a snake she's
literally wearing snakes on her legs and
up top I don't think that this is just
you know oh this is cool and TR no it
looks like a top that a teacher would
wear but the fact that she's wearing
that was not accident at all she what
she's doing and so she's highly inspired
by the Bible but totally flipping the
model as we're going to find out um
here's here's a guy he's just praising
her he's interviewing her but just what
he says at the beginning of this is just
really interesting and kind of her
response so check this out she's going
to tell you a little bit about what the
show is
[Music]
about Vivian this show is absolutely
incredible I love it I fell in love with
it as soon as I saw that intro about
Lilian and Lucifer it's incredible now
uh this show started as a Kickstarter in
2019 and it's going to be streaming on
Prime for those that aren't familiar
with the hasbin hotel um can you
describe the show yeah so so hasbin
hotel is about
this it's set in hell um it's about the
the daughter of Lucifer Charlie
Morningstar who is um trying really hard
to find a way to rehabilitate sinners in
hell because there's an overpopulation
problem and the way that heaven has
dealt with that because they're worried
that there might be an uprising is that
they come down every year to basically
exterminate as many as they can so
Charlie's like don't do that um please
those are my people and so she's trying
to come up with a way to to to redeem
Souls and and make you know hopefully
get them to Heaven that way and so she
makes this hotel called the hasband
hotel which is named by aler who's the
character that comes into help her as
like a kind of Chester cat you're not
really sure if he's good or evil but
she's got a lot of characters like that
that kind of her either helping or
hurting her her cause that's basically
what the show is about and it's a
musical okay so the setting is in Hell
who's the Redeemer but Lucifer the
Christ yeah the daughter of Lucifer so
Lucifer and Lilith fell in love had the
main protagonist whose name is Charlie
Morning Star and she's the Redeemer
she's concerned that hell's population
is getting really large and so Heaven
every year comes down and exterminates
everybody in hell because they're afraid
Heaven is afraid that hell is going to
get so populated that they can have an
uprising and I've seen that in other
other uh anime and and storylines where
they think that God is afraid of us like
the Matrix he said you're afraid of us
you're afraid you know when I tell
everyone that there's no rules and all
this stuff um there's always this story
of God is afraid of humanity or afraid
of demons being able to take over but
God doesn't have to fear anything he
created it all he's the most powerful
being in existence I think it's also
just the concept that it's possible for
humans to do that when clearly it's not
so I we see that with the Tower of Babel
yeah I mean it just is not
possible but yeah I'm baffled yeah she's
super sympathetic for Humanity and
basically it's painted in a way I've
seen some of the uh there's a a song
it's it's a it's a musical so it's
really catching to to people but there's
a song where Charlie is telling she's up
there in heaven and she's talking to an
angel who looks just terrifying he's got
this evil grin and everything and she's
saying look hell's really overpopulated
but I want to make this hotel it's a
rehabilitation and when they get good
then you can just take them to Heaven
instead of killing them every year and
the angel responds by saying no hell is
forever they've made their decision and
Tor torment is our entertainment CU hell
is forever whether you like it or not
have their chance to behave better now
they boil in the pot they're burning for
their lives until we kill them again
there's the question of
fun and for those of us with Divine
ordainment extermination is
entertainment how's that painting God
and His government he's a sadistic
tyranical dictator and that he gets off
to seeing people be tormented all day
yeah I mean this has so many so many so
many problems right um just the idea
that God is you know so stupid when he
judges Humanity he doesn't even know how
to make the right decision you know he
doesn't have the for Sight to see like
oh yeah you know what actually and deep
down in their heart they really could
have been good if they just had a little
more time you know yeah all that is
wrapped up in that like God is not a
just God exactly that he doesn't know
the difference between what's right and
what's wrong or that you know he doesn't
know ultimately what people are like in
their hearts so you know he just made he
made a bad decision that's that's really
essentially and that he doesn't value
Souls because if you can just carelessly
destroy them just every once a year it's
just crazy I'm just so confused as and
just disturbed by the woman on the news
channel who said you know this show
means so much to me like I'm really
questioning where she is in life and
what why is she dealing with issues
where she feels like this gives her hope
because maybe the church didn't or like
why is she connecting with this it's the
polarization of society you know the
Christian right is the
one well Christianity in general is is
basically Drawing the Line in the Sand
and morality and saying
this is what God finds acceptable we can
find it here in the Bible and this is
what he doesn't and the rest of the
world's like well I'm in that group and
I don't like that yeah therefore God I
don't like and so they have to find a
way it's like everybody's trying to find
a way to get around God and His rules
and his law so that they can be in
heaven too or do what they want do and
do what essentially do what they want
and be in heaven mhm we don't want to
surrender or obey we just want we don't
we want what we want and and essentially
what it ises is that you wind up
breaking the first commandment because
now God is not God you're God you're
making the decision even more sad than
than the lady that came on and saying
that you're an inspiration to me or
whatever is she's not alone yeah this is
a this is
number top 10 this is where this is what
our society is craving and and watching
and it's it's more than just the
storyline is based on
the daughter of Satan is redeeming
humanity and God is the villain it's the
whole thing is just explicit through and
through every other line is a cuss word
um there it's the perversion to the max
we're going to see all that stuff here's
the characters so Charlie Morning Star
her last name is Morning Star because
her father's name is Lucifer morning
starh what I what I find is interesting
I always hear people bring that up
Morning Star Jesus is actually the
Morning Star if you look in the Bible it
does call Lucifer son of the morning but
there's just kind of a a
misunderstanding there that's not a big
deal but same last name that they used
for the Lucifer Series yeah on TV he was
called Lucifer Morning Star
really
interesting um it it says you know we
lost so many Soul this is a quote this
is her pitch to to Heaven she said we
lost so many souls and it breaks my
heart to see my people being slaughtered
everywhere no one has even given a
chance I can't stand idly by while the
place I live is subjected to such
violence so I've been thinking isn't
there a more humane way to hinder
overpopulation here in Hell perhaps we
can create an alternative way to change
Souls through Redemption well I think
yes so that's what this project aims to
achieve ladies and gentlemen I'm opening
the first of its kind a hotel of
rehabilitating Sinners but her idea was
shot down and she
says there the these people haven't even
given a chance how about let's try a
little
Redemption did God not give people a
chance did God not send a redeemer right
exactly that's where I was going to they
don't want that one not that way yeah
anyway but Jesus wasn't wasn't that in
Fight Club too he's like no more
Redemption No Redemption is that was
part of it like I think so I think that
was so you see over and over and over
the program that's been pushed and I I
think it's laughable when people say
don't don't shove your beliefs down my
throat when they're talking about
Christians how much Christianity shoved
down your throat the little tracked in
the bathroom the one or two stations on
TV and the radio and all day long New
Age whether it's a candy bar commercial
mattress New Age The Occult witchcraft
always shov down your throat and nobody
complains about it mhm in fact they
embrace it yeah I think it's because new
age is sold in a way that just looks
good and you also have to consider
people's upbringing because usually the
whole Christian thing it starts in
childhood and however your parents
treated you and and they claimed to be
Christian and if there was abuse in that
that leaves a very bitter taste in
people's mouths and that naturally makes
people rebel which I still think is
wrong because the Bible also says do not
provoke your children like people love
to quote like everything yes to Wrath um
but it's just like there's so many
things that go into it and you know I
read this um actually no someone said
this quot I went to this like live talk
and they said the devil knows that if he
can fight early he doesn't have to fight
hard later right and so it's like if you
can get them when you're when they're
little they start to just move on with
the lies on their own and I was just
like whoa so there's so like those seeds
planted matters and I think that's
probably an attack that the enemy just
kind of loves to um like just the
Christian family and just making it over
um what's the word I don't know just not
too strict but just in a way that's not
godly it's not God's intention it just
becomes this very strict rule-based no
Freedom no love type of thing and then
you just grow up resenting that you're
like I don't want this and then you see
new age that's like freedom and love and
embrace yourself and you know and it's
just that's what you're chasing is that
connection that you no longer associate
with Christ right I was going to say you
hit it right on the head I think because
freedom is what we're after then all of
a sudden if we're not acceptable to the
church or to our parents and this is all
under the GU like a guise or a title of
Christ which is mistaken in that case
then they go Looking For Freedom
elsewhere but true Freedom comes from
Christ exactly
and even his law is a law of Liberty
because when you love God and you love
your neighbor that's true Freedom you
live in a world with no pain and no
misery don't steal from your neighbor
don't lie don't cheat all these things
are good moral things that most people
believe in but you have to agree on that
and that's that's the thing is there's
no you know someone can say oh well
stealing is wrong but they can say okay
but from who because what you know like
there's so many like different things
that people like to just like these
loopholes they like to take and know
exactly and so everyone has their own
you know you've heard the phrase my
truth my reality there is no just
reality there's no just plain truth and
so I think yeah which is exactly what
this is teaching because there's another
song I didn't really put that part in
there but there's a part where uh she's
saying the angel is saying there's
there's black and white there's rules
and she's like no this if this person
would have had time they would have had
a a chance to be redeemed yeah the rules
are and there's no to fight
it
lives again the Bible says in Romans 8
it says for to be carnally minded his
death but to be spiritually minded is
life and peace because the carnal mind
is enmity against God for it is not
subject to the law of God nor indeed can
be and then in Romans 7 right before
that it says for we know that the law is
spiritual but I am carnal sold under sin
that's really what the problem is is our
human nature is at war with what God
desires for us you know our sinful
nature is a war with the nature he
really desires for us and so when we put
ourselves first there's always going to
be a conflict and you're never going to
submit to those things that God is
asking to you that's why it says it's
not subject to the law of guard of
course not you're not subjecting
yourself to it you're saying no no it's
my way or the highway
yeah yeah wow yeah some of the other
characters this is Lucifer Morning Star
this is her dad and I just wanted to
show um that is it is in fact her he's
holding an apple he is holding an apple
yeah this is in fact the daughter of
Satan and he likes caramel apples so
there's a lot of this play on biblical
themes um this is like her best friend
or something what is his name Alis
That's Not Just some name just picked
out a hat what do you guys think
right okay everybody was unanimously
believed and I don't just think we're
reaching here because shows like
Supernatural had a guy named Alistair
and a guy named Crowley so shows that
talk about spiritual Concepts they know
that he is a blatant most occult you
know he said he was the wickedest man
alive he was a pedophile like why would
you glamorize somebody like that as
being the best friend it says here that
he is a the main protagonist somewhere
it said on the on the show he's he's
like best friends with Charlie so why
would you glamorize somebody who was a
pedophile occultist you know where else
it is Crowley's the bad angel in good
Omens see huh so look at this like they
always glamorize Alistar Crowley and
they they know who he is he's associated
with hell I mean these people are from
Hell U but you even see Lilith Lucifer
all these things and this was in the
show Supernatural which I don't know
anything about but I was just showing
that mainstream media shows they pick up
on this stuff and they use that that
dude's name was alist for a reason uh
she has this other friend whose name is
angel dust and he is an adult legs arms
yeah like a spider or something angel
dust is an adult adult film star in hell
and one of the main protagonists so now
you know not only is it Lucifer's
daughter is the protagonist aliser cwy
is a protagonist but also a porn star
why are we glamorizing these things and
a drug reference I'm gonna what and a
drug reference yeah angel dust I'm going
to point out that it says Anthony
Anthony Anthony more commonly known as
angel dust so is
that a HEI thing going on well it says
gender is drag queen all right we do
have it's a sinner demon but sexuality
is gay gender
gender is male there's also a huge play
on the black and white contrast look at
the eyes so a gay male porn star drag
queen sex worker this is somebody that
we're glamorizing and glorifying as a
protagonist well look at the position of
the second
arms what do you mean Point like isn't
that in the baffet Statue where one's
pointed up one's pointed
down both so below so I I wanted to
point out that you know Charlie she's
gay her lover is a female so the main
protagonist is bisexual actually but
she's a in a lesbian relationship right
now her best friend's gay so I was
curious like okay it's it's rated TV MA
it's not for kids but this was um on
Reddit in the official has been Hotel
thing three years ago so this just got
picked up by Amazon Prime but it's been
out for a couple years on YouTube and so
somebody was like I'm curious about the
Dem graphic that watches hasbin Hotel
this is from the fans this is imagine a
whole fan page asking what are your
ages this 15 to 19 category doubles any
other age group 15 to 19 are the highest
that's crazy population of people
watching this disgusting satanic
perverted in every kind of way show I'm
still yeah
I'm there they got on the internet and
voted they have to be at least between
five to seven wow maybe or like 5 to 10
so just for anybody that thinks you know
well this is protected it's for adults
only it's not me and Keith when we
opened up the prime and was looking at
these music videos and everything that
were cussing every word you we weren't
even signed in we weren't signed in
there was no thing that said sign in
because this is age appropriate or
whatever there's nothing preventing a
kid from watching this stuff you
familiar with Common Sense Media yeah
yeah so they're kind of a watchdog group
have a lot of ratings and stuff so on
here the parents guide to has been a
hotel says 17 plus the
description says rampant sex profanity
violence in animation set in hell and
it's listed as a
comedy and yeah they have a whole
section on what to talk to your kids
about in here yeah well we're going to
look at some of that too from Internet
Movie Database the parents guide I only
clicked on sex and nudity not drugs or
anything else violence and Gore I mean
there's a there's many this show has
everything but I only looked at the sex
and nudity and it says there's a
building called porn Studios there are
multiple blatant sex jokes and inuendos
sex and prostitution are mentioned and
shown in various episodes sex is very
frequently mentioned and joked about
nudity and porn are frequently mentioned
and shown on screen however no onscreen
genitalia is shown sexual harassment
sexual abuse frequently occur this is
usually played for laughs but sometimes
handle a serious matter I want to know
when is sexual abuse ever funny right
when can you put when can you portray
sexual abuse in the in the era of me too
and make a joke out of it and it's one
of the biggest things watched on on
television yeah
how does this happen like it's it's like
the cancel culture only picks and
chooses what they want to cancel like if
it's Pepe
Lew all right Sher the courtship is
[Music]
over getting there is cancel culture now
coming for Looney Tunes characters the
French skunk Pepe Leu has reportedly
been cut from the upcoming Space Jam
sequel after a New York Times columnist
claimed the character perpetuates rape
culture
that New York Times oped not only called
to cancel a Pew but also his fellow
Looney Tune character Speedy Gonzalez
accused of being a quote corrosive
Mexican stereotype okay so pep Lew a
Looney Tunes cartoon can be cancelled
because he's going after this cat and
you know oh and all this stuff as a rape
but when you blatantly have sex abuse as
a joke in BDSM sex toys fre referred to
and shown not just that I feel like what
would prepare you for this is watching
stuff like Family Guy and these other
shows and I remember um was it uh
Cartoon Network way back and I don't
know if they still have it they had like
this one section after all the kids
programming was done yeah Adult Swim I
feel like that's what prepares you for
this like no one just wakes up in the
morning and says oh I actually really
like this show like there had to be some
type of progression to get here mhm
programming there and so you know what's
what's crazy I actually looked up the
demographics of this um and on
similarweb.com and it says that actually
a
majority of the gender distribution is
male H um it's 61.9% male and
38.2% women interesting because the
Creator is a woman but I'm thinking if
it's heavily sexual in this way then you
have to also think about um maybe like
anime porn or porn in general how that
like the like men dominate that
demographic um and so it's like it would
make sense because if you're not taking
women seriously you don't respect them
then you can see something like this and
it's like oh it's a cartoon it's funny
it has cartoons and it's like you know
they make them cute and whatever so it's
like I don't know it kind of makes sense
doesn't make it right but I mean that's
disturbing some occasional references to
beastiality or furry sex but yet a cross
or a manger scene is offensive in our
culture today so tell me this sexual
harassment and sexual abuse sexual abuse
is in this and at the bottom it says
gang rape is featured as a character
being Chained and choked Pepe Lew is
pushing
rape culture but we literally have gang
rape and sexual abuse and this is not
canceled tell me why and if there's a
such thing as hate speech is this
cartoon not hate speech against
Christianity it literally is and yet
it's being viewed by millions and
promoted by Amazon Prime so here's a a
clip just to show you how Gnostic this
is this is an angel apparently in heaven
and this is a song and you're going to
see how they paint God or the rulers of
heaven and how their government is
unfair but she was right
Sarah she showed us the soul can improve
he saw the light
Sarah checked all the boxes that you
said would prove a person deserves a
second chance now we turn our backs so
Second Glance it's not as simple as you
think not everything is spelled in it's
not fair
s to think that I admired you well I
don't need your
condion I'm not a child to protect with
talk of virtue just pretention would I
too ni to expect you to he the more
rules you're pering that's what the [__]
I've been
saying if hell is forever then Heaven
Must Be Alive if angels can do whatever
and remain in the sky the rules are
Shades of Gray when you don't do as you
say when you make theed suffer just to
kill them
again I was told not to trust in angels
wow so you hear the rules are Shades of
Gray when you don't even keep them is
what she's saying if if if angels are
allowed to sin and stay in the sky then
there must be Shades of Gray in here yet
you're not basically you're not
practicing what you're preaching well
she finds out here is that her lesbian
girlfriend is actually an angel who's
been hiding it all this time so there's
a lot of angels that are finding out the
truth about God and they're turning
their back on God and and telling you
know the world exposing God for being
being unrighteous I have I don't know if
you guys saw but while she's singing all
of a sudden this
big ey flashes on her chest as though
she's been given the third eye of
Enlightenment Enlighten and then all of
a sudden and that's what they say when
they're enlightened is I am God I can do
what I want and then it goes back to all
of a sudden being a cute little I don't
know bow or something or star on her W
you caught that that went right into my
subconscious I missed that wow I I think
too um it's interesting because I think
the reason why this can be so
encouraging to some people is because
okay for people to be encouraged by this
there had to be a narrative set up and
it seems like the narrative is you can't
do it like you're never going to be good
enough for God and you're just going to
end up in hell anyway because you're
never going to be what he wants you to
be and that's God knows that he says all
has fallen all have fallen short the
glory god and so it's just like it's
it's not about what you're doing it's
who you're surrendering too like you
know the fruit will come from that
relationship you have with Christ that's
the key though I think that you missed
and is the other part of the story is
the whole surrender part I'm the one
that should be surrendering to God not
demanding that God change because of my
choices correct right but that's the
thing surrendering is simple it's it's
not about making sure you feed every
homeless person it's not about making
sure that you never say a cuss word in
your life and if you do then you're
going to hell it's not action based it's
when you surrender to Christ the fruit
will come from that but surrendering is
hard in a way in terms of like it is
conflicting with the carnal nature so
that's the hard part about it Charlie or
the the angel that was singing in the
beginning said this person did check off
all the boxes that you said were needed
or whatever and yet you still didn't let
them because they're already in hell for
one this is somebody who already died
they're already in hell and now they're
now that they're in hell now they're
going to check all the boxes and try to
get to heaven well it's too late you
know but they're saying that that's
unfair you should let these people be
redeemed which uh by you know you would
obviously have to result to well Satan
needs a chance too right this is
Sympathy for the Devil you know how come
Satan can't have a chance to go to
heaven checking off all the boxes is the
way it all
happens it's very Works based exactly
that's what I was going to say Works
based or legalistic whatever they've
heard either from their upbringing or
church or bad friendship whatever it was
that they came across Christians or that
Narrative of Christians believing that
it's all about just checking boxes then
they all got turned against it and yeah
went for this instead like it speaks to
their heart because they're bitter about
what they've experienced and I think
what's crazy too is watching this you
already get the sense of like I'm
already doomed when that's a lie Satan
is the only one who has the secure fate
in this whole thing he is going to hell
and every other person they still have
the choice to get out in reality not in
the show but in reality it doesn't
matter what like where you are in life
there is still a possibility for you to
come to Christ if you make that decision
Lucifer is not redeeming anyone he's
trying to Dr people as as there's breath
in your lungs on the cross is a prime
example of that we have an example of
somebody who was dying because of
something they were being put to death
because of something they did was wrong
they were guilty all the way to the
point of death and he still surrendered
to Christ said I recognize you're the
Son of God you're the only way I'm going
to get to go please remember me in your
kingdom and Christ said you'll see me in
and Jesus didn't say oh well you didn't
chck off the boxes you didn't you spent
your whole life sing he said you will be
with me in Paradise mhm yeah I know the
one eye symbolism everywhere so this is
the the two-minute intro that kind of is
very uh Gnostic and some of us already
seen this but I'll go ahead and show
this for if this is your first time ever
seeing this be talked about this is the
setup of the whole the plot of the whole
show Once upon a time there was a
glowing City protected by Golden Gates
known as heaven it was ruled by beings
of pure light angels that worshiped good
and shielded all from Evil Lucifer was
one of these angels He was a dreamer
with Fantastical ideas for all of
creation but he was seen as a
troublemaker by the Elders of Heaven for
they felt his way of thinking was
dangerous to the order of their world so
he watched as the Angels began to expand
the universe in their ways from the dust
of Earth they created Adam and Lilith
equals as the first of mankind but
despite this Adam demanded control and
Lilith refused to submit to his will she
fled the garden drawn in by her Fierce
Independence Lucifer found her and the
two rebellious dreamers fell deeply in
love together they wished to share the
magic of Free Will with Humanity
offering the fruit of knowledge to
Adam's new bride Eve who gladly accepted
but this gift came with a curse for with
this single act of Disobedience evil
finally found its way into Earth with it
a new Realm of Darkness and sin and the
order Heaven had worked to maintain was
shattered as punishment for their
Reckless act Heaven cast Lucifer and his
love into the dark pit he had created
never allowing him to see the good that
came from Humanity only the cruel and
the wicked ashamed Lucifer lost his will
to dream but Lilith rived empowering
demonkind with her voice and her songs
and as the numbers of Hell grew so did
its power threatened by this Heaven made
a truly heartless decision that every
year they would send down an army an
extermination to ensure hell and its
Sinners could never rise against
them but Lilith's hope remained and her
dream was passed down to their precious
daughter the prince princess of
hell don't worry Mom I'll make you proud
I feel like I just w i
just like saw an animation of what's in
the Satanic Bible even though I never
read it I feel like I literally now know
what's in theic Sunday school this is
the story guys of how Lucifer was kicked
out but he's going to save the universe
but when they were showing
Lucifer and Lilith falling in love it
was a gray screen with the tree in
between there was a serpent coming down
out of it and two it almost appeared
that two women were standing there yeah
I saw that suddenly with hair in the
wind and then there two women women all
of a sudden is it Lilith and Eve yeah
cuz that's he's about to give Eve
the got and now the serpent actually
turns in the Satanic Bible story and he
gives her the gift of free will we
didn't mention that but it's God that
gives free will right but in this story
it's Satan that's offering the gift of
Free Will
mhm wow he just gave her the option to I
mean he just gave her the or presented
her the opportunity to choose she
already had Dad yeah she already had
free will but he just presented the bad
opportunity to her like hey now that you
have the choice you should actually pick
it right you know so he didn't offer her
anything she didn't have already that's
right well he did offer her that's true
that's true mhm that's actually true
this is in the top 10 of everything
watched in the world I'm not
surprised if somebody had the budget to
make an amazing animation like this and
it was based on how there's a loving
father in the sky and he wants to he's
saving people he's protecting Humanity
from demons because he's going to create
a perfect world for them to live in
where they can live forever in a perfect
world with no pain and no sorrow would
it be picked up by Amazon Prime watched
by millions upon millions of people no I
think it might be picked by Amazon Prime
but it will not be
promoted they do they do have bible
stuff on there like Bible stories but
they're not from like you'd have to just
I mean every every streaming site does
like they'll have your Messiah or not
Messiah but the that's not a good show
that is not a good so um I metant the
one um young Messiah I think that's the
one um when he was little a lot of
creative interpretation there but yeah
they have Esther Bible Story series so I
but I don't think it would be promoted
right and you know it's it's true that
the the way to destruction is Broad you
know millions of people are watching
this but just a few people find that
narrow gate to life it only comes
through Christ you can't get to God by
any other way he's the way Jesus the way
not a way there's not many ways to God
there's one and millions of people are
thinking that this is something that
they want to watch mhm I think what's
crazy is we have to
unlearn what beauty isn't because I mean
God is the author of beauty and he's a
creative God but it's like when you see
stuff like this all the time growing up
you have to unlearn that like we in our
natural state do not find God at
attractive like that's something that
has to come with time um you know
because I know for me like before I
remember before when I started first
watching this channel I mean there were
a lot of things I just didn't see like I
it was just what I was used to and I had
to learn over time now I'm to the point
where I'm just like wo like I can't
believe at one point I just used to
think nothing of this and I would just
consume it but yeah American Horror
Story was her favorite show okay you
don't have to call me out hey you you
admit it I mean I I used to consume
metal music in horror movies all the
time yeah but I would already turned I I
wasn't even trying to find out at that
point yeah um yeah this is I mean it's
it's pretty shocking you know that this
is mainstream now and I think if you
showed this trailer to somebody in the
30s they might have a heart
attack oh in the 1930s yeah
right I mean what if you I mean I just
can't imagine somebody from the past
travel into the future and they turn on
the TV and this is what they see they
just be like that would be like sensory
overload and they probably wouldn't know
what's going on like like I've died and
gone to Hill like yeah like why is God a
woman and why there's so many things on
ground Day made a music video That's
Right M yeah like ke said there's so
many things to break down in there we
actually have a video uh just breaking
down this trailer alone if you guys want
to watch that it's going to be at the
end you can click that the link will be
in the description but uh in this we
broke down a lot of stuff about who
these characters represent who's
watching this stuff how if you promote
sexual violence in the right way maybe
it's acceptable but if you're pep Pew
you get canceled I don't understand how
that works but these are making me think
of some scriptures in the Bible Isaiah
5:20 says woe unto them that call evil
good and good evil that's exactly what
this show is doing that put Darkness for
light and light for darkness that put
bitter for sweet and Sweet for bitter
this is a a description of the last days
if you can't see that that's what the
majority of mainstream media and pop
culture is promoting then you're just
blinded by the enemy because that's what
is happening and we are living in the
last days no doubt makes me think of
Revelation 129 when it says the Great
Dragon which was cast out that old
serpent called the devil and Satan which
deceives the whole world he was cast
into the Earth and his angels were cast
out with him Satan's here his demons are
here and he's deceiving the entire world
to the point to where we're being
entertained by his gospel his side of
the story that says God is a tyrannical
villain and Lucifer is actually Our
Redeemer you know I had learned
something recently um I'm reading a
commentary on the Book of Revelation as
you go through there the author is
breaking down a lot of different things
in in Greek um because that's what it
was written in and when you read
the word
600 60 and 6 in Greek it's very
fascinating when you look at root words
they all begin with something you would
recognize really yeah because um
hex meaning six right right is the root
is is the the prefix to all of the all
of the words or you know in in in the
Greek what is a hex like a spell Cur a
curse a spell or a curse and it's
mentioned you know three times wow um of
course it in in it's talking about the
number but then that number has been
also reassociated if you will in the
modern vernacular to mean uh you know
bewitching or a curse or a spell that
you put on people and of course
obviously coming from that yeah you know
because this this where it all goes back
to there's actually on this show there's
a news channel called 666 news like they
just Embrace everything satanic it was
he pentagrams and everything it's just
crazy but we are definitely living in
these last days Revelation 13:4 says and
they worshiped the dragon which gave
power into the Beast and they worshiped
the Beast saying who is like him who is
like the Beast who is able to make war
with him I'm
like I used to see this as a kid and I
was like how could the world in the 90s
and I'm like how could the world ever
worship Satan yeah that sucks well and
that that last sentence here is is
exactly the mentality that you're
watching is like hell is such a force to
be reckoned with you know who can make
war with hell I mean you know God's
afraid they could they could uprise and
take it over so he's got to nip it in
the bud quick yeah and so what what used
to seem like a
inconceivable thing is now like we're
there we're unveiling bit statues we're
entertaining ourselves by shows that
glamorize perversion and
Satanism what's crazy though is like you
asked the question how would people ever
worship Satan I mean look at how even
though the characters around him are
evil and they're doing weird stuff he
portrays himself like Christ in a way
like the redemer you know like you
should feel sorry for him because he
just really wanted to do good in the
world and he's a dreamer and he's a
rebel in the most beautiful way and
that's what the Bible also says he he'll
he'll appear like an angel of Light and
so that's how people can worship him
because they're deceived that's the
scary part is he doesn't like Satan
doesn't care whether you know you're
worshiping him or not mhm it say as long
as you're not looking at God and you
don't know who he really is he's like
that's a side even though we may think a
middle ground exists it doesn't either
for exactly so he's like if I if you're
just there then okay so it's it's why
it's important that you have
relationship this is where it breaks
down in
Eden it breaks down at the relational
level we know God by his
characteristics right you're going to
also understand what's not God
by its
characteristics it's not it's it's the
appearance is easy just like you said
it's easy to change right we can change
the facade flip that in and out um Satan
does that to suit his liking but the
characteristics M those never change
right right yeah that's that's how
propaganda works you know like people
look at Thanos and they're like oh he
couldn't be like Jesus look he's mean
and purple well that's just that's like
spr painting a square mustache on
somebody you know it everything that
Thanos represents is Christlike he's
sitting on a throne in a spaceship
called The Sanctuary in the heavens and
he's coming to Earth to snap his fingers
and Destroy half of humanity or separate
the sheep from the goats that's Christ
but the propaganda part is oh he's a big
scary purple alien guy yeah and so
that's what's happening here as well
they could portray the the angels in
heaven as these menacing Grins and
they're destroying people but you know
the Lucifer he's all like oh a dreamer
that's creative so many little things
you notice the angels that went to
create like exclusively from Lucifer you
know keep him out there were four of
them which makes me think of the four
living creatures right oh yeah and when
it was talking about God in the
beginning it had all these eyes right
which is also symbolic in Revelation yep
the lamb lamb with seven eyes right I I
bet that is the four living creatures
because they all a little different yeah
they made them all like these biblically
accurate um strange creatures and things
I thought the way they portrayed the
angels in this show was very interesting
too cuz there's more like AI images of
what Angels really look like going about
so it's no longer these humanlike beings
it's like the weird wheel within a wheel
wheel in a wheel eyes yeah with wings
scary stuff that if it said do not fear
i' definitely afraid but God is so cool
in his creation you look at spiders and
snakes and things that are underwater
yeah I don't doubt that he has some
interesting looking Creations up in
heaven you know yeah uh this is the last
verse I have Revelation 16:14 because
this is really what is happening Satan
is preparing the world to fight Christ
we know Jesus is coming soon like we
look at all the signs around us Jesus is
coming soon and Satan has something that
he's going to do it it says for there
are the spirits of devils working
miracles which go forth to the kings of
the earth and of the whole world to
gather them to the battle of the great
day of God Almighty Satan is forming an
army to fight against the coming of
Christ now it's uh it's a pathetic
attempt we nobody if we had the whole
world can fight Christ and win but if
Satan can deceive people into thinking
that Christ is some evil alien invader
that needs to be fought against and we
can only you know fight him if we join
sides with him or whatever then we're
giving our allegiance to Satan yeah
we're joining his army and and against
in an attack against Christ in a in a
attack that's really going to be our
demise so the historical background here
and and likely probably what John had in
in mind when he wrote it um this battle
Armageddon uh comes from a um Hebrew
term har megiddo which is is like the
valley of megiddo MH um the the
mountain that's near there it doesn't
say it here but there's another text in
in in in Revelation that alludes to this
is Mount
Carmel and what happened on Mount Carmel
it's this this essentially spiritual
battle that happens between Elijah and
the prophets of B right
and the whole determination in this
whole thing is about who is God right
and these prophets of Baal they go forth
like these spirits of the devil and what
are they're trying to do they're trying
they hope for a miracle right they wish
they had a miracle cuz they would have
lit that altar up in a second if they
could of course in a in a in a more
spiritual sense at the End of Time Satan
is able to succeed in that way God
allows him to you know work
deceptions um all for the purpose of
gathering you know Gathering Satan wants
to gather everybody to his side but
that's that's probably the historical
link that John had in mind when he wrote
this do you think that that Satan is
going to try to fight Christ when he
comes like a physical battle yeah I
don't I don't think
that's I don't think I mean it does say
you think of the Ridiculousness like how
do you fight but it does say that God
that the Wicked Will Rise Up on the
breadth of the earth Encompass the city
of the Saints and try to take it over by
force and sure try but what what does
that look like what does that mean and
what and and what is God going to do I
mean all he has to do is like say and
that's what leads me to think like does
Lucifer or does Satan actually believe
like does he know he's lying or does he
just believe that he actually can do
this you know that wor kind of
deception self deception self-deception
so you think he doesn't he really is
just delusional yes he's what we call
today
dulu I haven't heard that sure even like
Psychopaths and others narcissists and
such get to a certain point where they
believe their own lie yeah they don't
know themselves anymore that
is crazy and and if you're going to go
around promoting a lie all the time you
just about to have to be at the point
where you do believe it y otherwise how
do you convince everybody else mhm so
how does he like that's just crazy
because for you to have a show where
you're like you know even with Lucifer
the TV show it was still like oh like
woe to me like God kicked me out of
Heaven I just really wanted to like do
really good things for
people that means he doesn't even know
he's
lying like he
just he's self-consumed that's nature
crazy number one the first sin was Pride
but yeah well if you guys think we're
living in the last days give this video
a thumbs up I sure believe we are if you
know somebody that might be interested
in something like this or a parent that
has kids that might be interested in
this please share this with them because
awareness is uh part of the first step
you know we want to expose Satan's
deceptions if you've never seen this
channel click subscribe click the Bell
we'll uh it'll update you on videos that
come out we have a show like this every
Friday we also have little smaller
videos that come out throughout the week
if you want to support this channel you
can do so by going to Little Light
studios. TV there's a donate button
there and you want to wear a t-shirt we
got a lot of cool shirts on lightwear do
shop where you can really wear your
witness these are uh opportunities to be
able to break the ice and share W um not
that shirt though this one is not this
is a a friend of mine's Ministry but
yeah if you want to wear your witness
it's a great Icebreaker to talk about
spiritual things and biblical things and
if you have little ones and you don't
want them exposed to trash like this
then go subscribe to little light kids
where we're producing um content that's
safe and suitable and most of all
biblically sound for kids and we'll see
you next Friday thanks for tuning in
[Music]
guys
do you have questions about the Bible
that you've been struggling to find the
answers for video Bible study or VBS for
short is a YouTube channel that answers
your Bible question questions in 5
minutes or less check out these easy to
understand comprehensive videos talking
about everything from what happens when
you die to why does God allow suffering
make it your goal to deepen your
relationship with Christ this year and
subscribe to video bible study on
YouTube to help you along your
[Music]
journey
n